Narrator: It's been 10 years
since "Shark Tank"
ignited America's
entrepreneurial spirit,
and we're still
blazing a trail
for those who take their fate
into their own hands.
And tonight, Jamie Siminoff,
the founder of video‐security
phenomenon Ring,
which sold to Amazon
for over $1 billion,
is the first
"Shark Tank" entrepreneur
to return to the Tank
as a Shark.
You're talking
to a bunch of Sharks
that don't remember
what it's like to be little.
Oh, you're so full
of [bleep]
‐Kevin, I love you!
‐What?
I didn't come here today
to fight you about my valuation.
Stop, because it's not going to
become an overnight success
'cause nothing does.
‐Ruh‐roh.
This is our first date,
and you're very defensive.
[ High‐pitched voice ]
I'm offering you $600,000.
[ Laughs ]
Are you gonna
blow up my phone a lot?
I'm sorry,
but you're out.
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a business that fights back
against a common nuisance.
♪♪
My name is
Roger Anderson.
And I'm
Steve Berkson.
And we're here to tell you
all about
The Jolly Roger
Telephone Company.
We're seeking $400,000
for 10% equity
in our company.
Throughout history,
predators have tried
to sneak into our homes.
These strangers
don't use doors.
They don't use windows.
They use...
telephones.
Who are they?
They're...
telemarketers.
Last year alone,
they scammed Americans
out of $9.4 billion.
‐Mm.
‐I knew somebody had to do
something about this.
Having worked in telecom
my whole life,
I thought, "Perhaps I'm the guy
for the job."
So I hoisted my flag,
sailed the telecom seas,
and started The Jolly Roger
Telephone Company ‐‐
the answering service
that fights back.
With our service,
telemarketers think
they're getting
exactly what they want ‐‐
a long conversation
with a receptive,
gullible consumer.
But instead,
they're interacting
with humanlike robots ‐‐
we call them pirates ‐‐
specially designed
to keep scammers talking,
wasting their time, and
draining away their ability
to make any money.
[ Cellphone beeps ]
Robot #1: Hello?
Scammer #1:
Uh, yes, hello, sir.
Uh, my name is Eric.
We are in your neighborhood
this week.
Do you have
a couple minutes?
You know,
I was having trouble
concentrating 'cause you sound
exactly like somebody
I went to high school with.
[ Chuckles ]
So, sorry.
Say that part again.
[ Laughs ]
Okay. We're in
your neighborhood this week,
and I'd like to schedule
someone to come by your home
and, uh, help you,
give you an estimate...
Yeah.
Oh, geez. Hang on.
Oh, okay, great.
There's a bee on me.
Hang on.
[ Laughter ]
Stay on the line.
[ Cellphone beeps ]
Robot #2: Hello?
Scammer #2: Hi, this is Ronnie
from online technical support,
and we got information
that your computer
is getting hacked.
Do you know
anything about this?
Hello?
‐Mom!
‐Mm‐hmm.
Yeah?
Robot Daughter: Are you almost
done with the phone?
I want to finish
this episode.
Yeah, wait. Wait!
‐Okay, go on. Go on.
‐It'll only take 10 minutes.
‐[ Groans ]
‐Stop. Come on.
It's not fair.
You always do this!
Oh, my gosh.
I don't ‐‐ I ‐‐ You know,
I don't know if you have a ‐‐
like, a teenage daughter
at home.
You don't even know!
It's like ‐‐
This is,
like, really, like ‐‐
You're gonna
have to start again
because I'm completely
distracted.
I don't know what you said
from the beginning
because she's, like,
making me crazy.
[ Cellphone beeps ]
‐That's great.
‐Nice.
Greiner: Wait, how do you know
when they call
to set off the robot
versus it's someone
you really want to talk to?
Very good question.
We use
a third‐party service
that gives us a reputation score
for every caller I. D.
So, there are services
out there
that have hundreds of thousands
of honey‐pot numbers
throughout the U. S., and
they can spot in real time
when the same caller I. D.
is calling throughout the U. S.
Cuban: But, you know,
the best scammers already know
what's in the database
and go out there and create,
you know, Google Voice
phone numbers.
That's correct.
But ‐‐ But as soon as they
start hitting 1,000 numbers,
that reputation score
goes up as likely spam.
‐But you're saying ‐‐
‐It's an ongoing battle.
I‐I always think skeptics,
like Sharks ‐‐
and you're getting
some skepticism here...
Yes, yeah.
...can be put aside
by simply telling us
why you're worth
$4 million.
$400,000 for 10% ‐‐ you must
have a lot of sales, right?
We are pre‐growth ‐‐
We're a pre‐revenue company.
Oh!
[ Laughter ]
I'm curious.
What's your backgrounds,
and how did you
come up with this?
I work on telephone systems.
I'm a telephone engineer.
I fell in love with phones
in my 20s.
I'm just
a telephone geek.
So you're old‐school
old school.
Old school, definitely.
I'm also in
telecommunications,
about 30 years
in the business.
So, I had a telemarketer call
and swear at my son.
My son was
14 years old.
My son's upset, I'm mad,
and that's when I started
working on a robot
that would get their
most expensive asset on the line
and then just keep them talking
as long as possible.
See, I think
it's your civic duty
to waste the time
of a telemarketer.
You work your full‐time job,
and this is like
a moonlighting thing?
We work 40 hours a week
for our employers,
and then we work
60 hours a week on this.
O'Leary: What do you make a year
off a customer?
What does it cost you
to acquire them?
to service them?
So, customers will ‐‐
The subscription
is $12 per year.
Yes.
It costs us
about $4 per year.
Cuban: Why so much? Why does it
cost you $4 per year?
O'Leary: What does it cost you
to acquire the customer?
We're learning.
We have spent nothing on
customer acquisition so far.
Okay, so back to my question.
Why does it cost you $4?
'Cause that's high.
It is high.
We have hosting fees,
telecommunications fees,
gateway fees.
But how long
do they keep it for?
Because you don't know
that yet.
You don't know what
the attrition's gonna be.
We are very early on.
However, we've spent
two years in R&D.
And over that time, we realized
that we had to have a full ‐‐
a website that gave them
full control of everything.
We're rolling
that out now.
And when I go on
this website,
will I be able
to tell
how many have
tried to call me,
or is just ‐‐
‐Yeah, no, everything.
‐That's right.
‐You get the recordings.
Oh, you get the recordings,
as well?
That's the best part!
That's the most
satisfying part.
It's so funny.
[ Laughs ] That's great.
Look, guys, this is a feature
rather than a product, right?
This is not
my type of business.
I'm out.
Okay.
Greiner: You know,
I really like the idea,
and I love
the revenge of it,
but I don't think
I get the concept fully yet,
so I'm out.
♪♪
I'm interested. So, my issue
with it is $400,000.
You're both working
full‐time jobs right now.
There's no company here,
so how much money
do I need to invest
in order to have a business?
Because usually when you
invest in a business,
there's a business.
We're ready now.
We have the servers in place,
the website in place,
the telephony systems
in place.
But you both have
full‐time jobs.
We're ready to scale, and
we're gonna leave our jobs.
We expect there to be a very
steep growth curve for this.
[ Chuckles ]
We know the demand.
Tell them the story
about when you first ‐‐
'Cause we haven't done
any advertising.
We haven't needed it.
I'd like
to tell you a story.
Blackbeard used to light
his beard on fire
and then jump on the opposing
ship he was attacking.
[ Laughter ]
He was crazy.
This is gonna
grow like crazy.
But he won
a lot of battles.
See what happens
when stories get told?
So, we've processed
over a million calls
for customers
since we turned this on.
The fun and whimsical part
is great,
and that's how word of mouth
is spreading
with no money
in marketing.
So, I‐I‐I ‐‐ Stop.
Somebody does an article in
the paper, and it goes insane.
I'm all for everything
you're saying.
You're saying the same thing
over and over again.
Yeah, okay, sorry.
I'm ready to write a check
for $400,000.
Okay.
I need to know where
the money's going to go.
Because it's not going to become
an overnight success
'cause nothing does.
We want to do
online marketing,
obviously, directly
to consumers, but ‐‐
O'Leary: You mean you want
to start calling people
and asking them ‐‐
[ Laughter ]
‐Thousands of telemarketers.
‐Telemarketers, that's right.
We know where
to find them!
We've already
got them calling us.
Just say no
to telemarketers.
What are you gonna do
with the money?
What's the plan
for the $400,000?
We want to work
through the carriers.
We recognize that if
we work through carriers,
our customer‐acquisition
cost
can go down
to virtually zero.
It's something that ‐‐
‐What would incentivize them?
You're gonna scale quickly
working with carriers?
Carriers ‐‐
We want a deal ‐‐
You know how long a deal
with a carrier's gonna take?
In the next year, we
want to be funded to do
a carrier deal, yes.
Yes.
‐Yeah, but why would you ‐‐
‐It's 18 to 24 months.
It could just be
an add‐on feature to
your existing service.
‐They won't do that.
‐There's no way.
I'm out.
O'Leary: Ouch. Look, guys,
I love the
"Revenge of the Nerds" aspect,
but we need
a little structure.
It's not a business
yet, okay?
The only way
I'd look at this deal ‐‐
it's very simple, and
I have no flexibility on it.
I'll give you $400,000.
I want 50%,
'cause you need
adult supervision.
You just do.
John: You know,
um, I love it.
I really get annoyed
by telemarketers.
I love the comedy.
I love the pirate stuff.
But when Jamie
started to ask you
what would you do
with the money,
you really didn't give him
a good amount of answers,
but even if you gave me
the answers,
I wouldn't know if
it's the right answers,
'cause I just don't speak
that language,
so, uh,
with that being said,
I'm out.
‐So, he's the only Shark...
‐So, as usual,
all roads lead
to Mr. Wonderful.
What do you want to do?
‐Yeah, I don't ‐‐ I'm ‐‐
Mr. Wonderful, you have
to appreciate
we can't give up
50% of the company.
‐What company?
‐So we would love ‐‐
[ Laughter ]
Greiner:
I don't often say this,
but I think Kevin
could really help you
and that his valuation
here is fair.
If you want,
I'll come in
50/50 with you.
‐Did you hear that?
‐But I want 60%.
I'll come in half ‐‐
60% for $400,000.
O'Leary: Two incredible Sharks,
we want 60%.
We each put up $200,000,
and then you have
a real company.
The counter would be
20% for $400,000.
Never. Never. Never.
‐So, are you out?
‐Guys.
I'll do 25% each
for 50% for $400,000...
‐Ooh! I'll do that.
‐...if you're in for that.
‐You're back to the 50%.
‐That's a really good idea.
We're four of us.
We're partners.
I'd like to put this
all in perspective
and just tell you
a quick story.
No. You've got
to give him an answer.
[ Sighs ]
There's two main things
we haven't talked about.
Kevin, you know what?
[ Stammers ]
I'm cold.
I can't hear
any more stories.
We are countering.
I couldn't do this.
I'm out.
Argh, Billy! I'm out.
♪♪
‐[ Groans ]
‐Good luck, guys.
‐I love what you're doing.
‐Congratulations.
Thank you very much
for all the good advice.
Thank you.
‐Thank you very much.
♪♪
We came into the Tank
looking for a partnership.
And, instead, the offer
was more like an acquisition.
We're not selling this company.
We're building this company.
♪♪
Hi, I'm Eli.
And I'm Jen from
Bottle Breacher.
We just wanted to say
thank you to "Shark Tank"
for helping
veteran companies
transition from the military
to the private sector.
We've not only been able
to hire a lot of veterans,
but we've also been able
to raise a lot of awareness
about veteran issues.
We also want
to thank "Shark Tank"
for being an entertaining,
educational TV show
that our whole family
can watch.
♪♪
Breacher up.
Narrator:
Next up is a modern‐day toy
that fuels imagination.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks. I'm Ben.
And I'm Jenn.
And we're co‐founders
of Toybox.
We're asking
for $150,000
for a 5% stake
in our company.
When I was a kid,
I used to build cities
out of mud in my backyard.
And I used
to raid dumpsters
for parts to see what type
of crazy things I could build.
Kids have always had
a ton of potential
and a huge appetite
to create,
but often lack the opportunity
to build their vision.
So we've come up with
a more powerful way
for kids to build and design
toys the way the want to.
Introducing Toybox,
the first‐of‐its‐kind 3‐D
printer and creativity platform
built entirely
with kids in mind.
And with the Toybox app, you can
immediately start printing
with absolutely
no prior training.
So, how's it work?
Simply find the toy you want
and press print.
Toybox will instantly beam down
your toy and start printing.
And if you're feeling more
creative, you're in luck.
Welcome to the creator space
of the app.
Here, kids can design
and print their own toys.
So whether you're drawing
simple things
or designing
your own block buddies,
Toybox can fuel
your creative needs.
So, Sharks,
let's invest
in the next generation
of young minds
and turn this Toybox
into a money box.
And, of course,
we have samples.
Cool.
‐Thank you.
‐How cute.
‐I got a lobster.
‐Why a lobster for Daymond?
'Cause I used to work
at Red Lobster.
O'Leary: 'Cause he worked
That's right.
‐Oh!
And, Lori, we printed you
your own Scrub Daddy.
And, Mr. Wonderful,
we printed you
your one true love ‐‐
a big bag of money.
And, Jamie, we printed you
a shout‐out
to your
"Shark Tank" pitch ‐‐
a cutout
of Kevin O'Leary.
And, Mark, we know you're super
involved in basketball,
so we gave you ‐‐
You gave me a pumpkin?
‐A big, orange ‐‐
‐Orange, yeah.
[ High‐pitched voice ]
Oh, are you gonna give me
a license deal?
[ High‐pitched voice ]
I'm offering you $600,000.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐So, anyways, guys,
tell us about your business.
Baltes: So, uh, we built
most of this company
on an $80,000
investment.
Total, we've raised
around $290,000.
Chin:
And the reason we were able
to build this product
with such
a small investment
was because we're experts
in software.
We've worked at Microsoft
as developers and engineers.
Uh, I personally worked
in data science.
Greiner:
So, this isn't unique
in that 3‐D printers have been
out now for a while.
What's different is, is that
yours is specifically for toys.
And is it therefore smaller
and less expensive
than others
out there?
Yeah, so, we sell
this printer for $299,
which is definitely on the
cheapest end of 3‐D printers.
What we do specially
for kids
is we combine
hardware and software
to make a really friendly
user experience.
So, we have right now
over 750 toys.
We add 7 to 10 toys
a week,
and then we are
always monitoring
what kids
are playing with,
and we adjust what we add
based off of that.
Yeah, the worry with toys
is that it gets, you know,
used a couple times
and then put away.
And at $299,
that's a big decision on a toy.
O'Leary: What are
your sales like?
So, right now, we're focusing
just on Internet sales ‐‐
primarily sales
on our website.
We just started selling
in September.
We've done over $300,000
in sales since then,
and all we do
is advertise on Facebook.
Cuban: And what does it
cost you to make?
So, we buy this for $150,
we sell it for $299,
but there's nobody
on the market
that has this software
and hardware stack
that's so developed
for children.
Our biggest target demographic
is 6 to 9‐year‐olds.
And you can print toys
from famous media
like Disney,
Minecraft, Marvel,
LEGO,
all sorts of things.
Well, you have
to go license those.
I mean, that's ‐‐
Right.
So, licensing is
a huge opportunity.
Imagine if a kid
could, you know,
print his own Minecraft world
on this printer.
We see this as a huge,
huge, huge opportunity.
How long did it take
to print this out?
And how many passes?
So, that one takes
about four hours,
maybe about
eight passes.
You see,
there's the problem.
The attention span of
a 6, 7, 8, or 9‐year‐old
is gonna be difficult,
and I can see
the first couple times
Mom or Dad or whoever
helping them,
and that's great.
But no kid that age
has that attention span,
and I think that's
too big a challenge,
so for those reasons,
I'm out.
John:
So, guys, liability‐wise,
I mean, you're dealing
with 7‐year‐olds.
I mean, when I was 7,
I would have easily held my ‐‐
you know,
my parrot under there
to make some boots
for the parrot.
[ Laughter ]
You know, I'm just
a little afraid
of selling to a bunch of
6, 7, and 8‐year‐olds
where what can happen
will go wrong.
We do require
parental guidance, and ‐‐
You can say that
all you want,
but no parent
is sitting there
for four hours with them
and that machine's running,
and I'm just a little
concerned about that,
so for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you.
So, guys, you're a subset
of the toy business.
I mean, you really
have to find that parent
that's thinking,
"Investing $300 in my child's
imagination is a good thing,"
And I think that's cool,
but it's not everybody.
I like it, though, so
I'm gonna make you an offer.
I bring a lot of value
to this space.
That's the way I look at it.
But right now,
you're still at
the proof of concept.
You're basically
just starting out,
and I happen to think
licensing would help this,
and that's hard work.
I agree.
I'll give you
the $150,000 for 10%,
and the reason
I'm saying that
is that certain things
you want to do
will happen faster
with me driving this.
♪♪
Let me make it easier for you.
I love the mission.
I love ‐‐ I have
a 9‐year‐old son.
I would love the idea
that he'd play with this.
I think at $299
I just don't see it yet.
I hope you succeed
with it, though.
I'm rooting for you guys,
but I'm out as an investor.
Greiner: So, I think that ‐‐
O'Leary: Jenn and Ben...
Kids ‐‐
...I want you to know something.
If she drops out,
that gives me
a lot more incentive
to get friskier.
You know that.
Right.
Because you're starting
to lose Sharks here,
and I made you
an offer.
I‐I would ‐‐ I would love
to hear your offer, Lori.
Okay, before I was
so rudely interrupted ‐‐
Well, I'm just pointing out
a reality of the Shark Tank.
That's all.
[ Stammers ] Okay.
I was saying ‐‐
I think products like this
are really great
because they inspire kids
to build and design and develop.
The problem I have is,
is I think that
the age group you're targeting
is a little bit too young.
If it was the next
age bracket up,
like, 8 to 13,
I would like it better
as an investment for me.
But because it's not,
I'm out.
Thank you, Lori.
She didn't have an offer,
but you still
have an offer,
but it's going to be
modified slightly.
I'm feeling
very frisky now.
I don't like it
when I make an offer
and you're still
listening to others.
You have to realize
I have flexibility, too.
♪♪
Um, I want 15%,
not 10%.
♪♪
As usual, all roads
lead to Mr. Wonderful.
What are you gonna do?
Would you mind if we talk
about this for a little bit?
Sure, but...you know
what happens.
You don't want to really
leave the carpet.
♪♪
[ Indistinct whispering ]
All right, we'll do
$150,000 for 12%.
That's our
final deal.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐You think the difference ‐‐
You think the difference
of 3%, 300 basis points,
makes a difference?
I ‐‐ You either believe
that 15%'s worth it or not.
I bring a lot
to the table. No.
Cuban: 85% of a watermelon's
a whole lot better
than 100% of a grape.
♪♪
[ Indistinct whispering ]
All right,
we'll do 13% and ‐‐
[ Laughter and groaning ]
No, I'm not done.
And 2% in advisory shares.
13% and say it again?
2% in our advisory shares
from our pool.
♪♪
You have a deal.
‐All right.
‐Congratulations.
My goodness,
that was tough.
[ Chuckles ]
‐Congratulations.
‐Thanks, Kevin.
That's really good.
You did a good job.
Congratulations, guys.
‐We did it.
‐Yeah!
We probably should've
taken Kevin's first offer.
We do regret that a little bit,
but either way,
once he brings licensing
into the picture,
I think
we're gonna do great.
You know what?
Now that I think about it,
I should've asked
for 20%.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a way to
give meaningful gifts to kids.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Tanya Van Court,
and I'm from
Brooklyn, New York.
I'm the CEO and founder
of Goalsetter,
and I'm here today
seeking $200,000
in exchange for a 4%
equity stake in my company.
Wow.
Anyone with kids
can tell you
our children
get too much stuff.
From birthdays to holidays,
your houses are taken over
by toys and gifts
that your kids play with
just once,
if you're lucky.
[ Chuckles ]
Van Court:
By the time they're 12,
the average American child
has received almost
$7,000 worth of junk.
Gift‐giving for kids
needs a redesign,
and that's exactly
what Goalsetter is all about.
Rather than give kids more stuff
they don't need,
we provide a platform
that lets family members
and friends
give kids money to save
for goals that
they really care about.
With Goalsetter, there's no more
giving gift cards that say,
"I can't wait to see
what you buy next."
Instead,
family members and friends
can give GoalCards
and say,
"I can't wait to see
what you do next."
The money is deposited
into an FDIC‐insured
savings account
accessible through our site,
where kids can watch
their savings grow ‐‐
real money
towards real dreams.
Robotics camp, music lessons,
gymnastics, college ‐‐
it doesn't matter
what kids save for
because kids who have
savings accounts in their name
are six times more likely
to go to college
and four times more likely
to own stocks
by the time
they're young adults,
no matter how much
is in those accounts.
So, Sharks, if you want to truly
transform kids' futures,
join me in getting them
signed up
to save with Goalsetter.
So, Tanya, instead of
giving a toy to a child
when they open the gift ‐‐
their eyes light up
when they've got
a new basketball,
football, game, toy ‐‐
they get a certificate
with, like,
a $30 "go deposit this
into your account"?
Like, that ‐‐
that's just...
That's like a dream gift
for your kids.
‐That's pretty depressing.
‐[ Laughs ]
Well, it's actually
not depressing, Kevin,
because, you know,
you have kids.
You've seen how much stuff
kids already have.
Cuban: Okay, so, wait,
wait, wait.
Tanya, the bigger question
I have ‐‐
trying to create bank accounts
for kids is a disaster,
so tell us how you get
FDIC accounts set up
and how ‐‐ how it all works,
And then, of course,
we still need to hear
about your business.
So, you're right. Setting up
a savings account for kids
is absolutely
a nightmare,
which is why this is
such a great opportunity.
We set up
an FDIC‐insured account
for the parent ‐‐
in the parent's name ‐‐
and then the parent
can easily add their kids.
We've just recently been
accepted into an accelerator
with one of the three major
consumer banks in the country.
But then don't fees
become a significant issue?
No, fees aren't
a significant issue
because our ACH
transaction fees
are only 5 cents
every time we make a transfer,
So, gift‐giving is only one part
of our business, right?
But a second way kids get money
is by parents who say,
"I want to help you
save for this goal."
So, we have
the ability for parents
to set up auto‐save
so they can save a little bit
every week or every month
to help kids
with big goals over time.
Those could be ‐‐
‐It's like a piggy bank.
That's right, but it could be
college, or it could be,
"My kid wants to go to this
really awesome robotics camp,
but it's really expensive."
O'Leary:
How do you make money?
So, on the gift‐giving site,
we charge a dollar
for every GoalCard given,
minus the transaction fees,
which, as we talked about,
are 5 cents,
and the ACH
transaction fees.
The second way
that we make money
is with parents signing up
for any of
our savings features.
What do you
charge for that?
So, we have
historically charged
a dollar per month
per kid for that.
The third way is by taking
a percentage of assets
under management.
What's that part?
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Kevin!
‐Easy, easy.
‐That's what I ‐‐
‐I'm speaking your language.
‐No, no.
That's what
I know how to do.
Okay, so,
our partner bank,
which holds our assets,
will give us a percentage back
of those assets
under management.
How many basis points
are they gonna give you?
‐100 basis points.
‐What?
‐Yeah.
‐Are you serious?
Yeah.
That's a lot of money.
That's a ton.
‐Right, 1%.
‐Now you've excited him.
‐Whoo‐hoo!
I've never seen Kevin
breathe so hard.
Kevin's
hyperventilating here.
That is more than the entire
industry of services
in mutual funds,
in exchange‐traded funds,
in management fees
for people,
at brokerage houses,
online.
That's the highest fee
right now going.
How long
has this been ‐‐
that you've been public
with this for, or selling?
Van Court:
So, we've been selling since
about January of this year,
and we have about $40,000
under management right now.
How much money have you raised
to get to this point?
We've raised
$2.1 million.
I think it's very cool.
I have a similar thing.
It's basically charitable,
but I help kids invest
a fractional share ownership
in a product
called Beanstox.
You download the app,
and you buy 15 cents of Apple.
You actually own it.
Yep. Absolutely.
But the biggest problem
is customer acquisition.
So, our cost per acquisition
is about $10 per customer
right now,
But the interesting thing is
because of the Equifax
data breach over the past year
and all the security issues
that people have,
people are concerned about
connecting their bank accounts.
And so they need us
to be a known quantity
that they can feel good about
in order to do that.
Won't the new bank
help you with that
because of their brand?
‐Exactly. Kevin, I love you!
‐Everybody loves me.
‐[ Laughs ]
Tanya, I like your mission.
I like what you're doing.
I think it makes sense
in a lot of ways.
I think you're on your way
to getting there,
but I don't think
you're there yet,
and so for that reason,
I'm out.
No!
So, Tanya,
I love what you're doing.
The problem is,
it's so outside of what I do,
in terms of physical product.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Jamie, are you sure?
Maybe Amazon can sign up
to give all of its employees...
Cuban: Yeah, Jamie,
make that happen.
...as an employee benefit,
right?
‐I'm writing a note right now.
‐Thank you!
‐"Dear, Jeff..."
‐Right!
John: Well, here's what
I think about it.
You know, Minka,
my daughter, she's 2 1/2.
She doesn't
give anybody a hug
unless they have
a gift with them,
and for her
to open an e‐mail,
she probably just would
be like, "W‐What is this?"
[ Laughter ]
So, um...
I love the fact that you're
teaching financial intelligence,
but I just don't think
this one's for me.
I'm out.
Okay, well,
thank you, Daymond.
But what we have seen
when we have done testing,
for the younger kids,
they have so much stuff
that Mom is tired of
answering the calls like,
"What should I get Minka?"
‐Yeah, look,
aspirationally and goal‐wise,
it makes perfect sense, right?
Right?
You know, Tanya,
if you just said,
"Look, it's hard to open up
a bank account for your kids."
"Do it here." Yeah.
'Cause then you'd have
no overhead.
That's
an easy business.
You've complicated this
to no end.
I actually
don't think, Mark,
that this is
complicated to no end.
I think it's actually
super simple,
and what we've heard
from parents ‐‐
Wait, wait, look.
I appreciate what you're trying
to accomplish, but I'm out.
Mark, you got
to come back in.
Let me finish telling you!
‐Tanya, stop, stop, stop.
O'Leary:
Look, I work with all these
banks you're talking about,
and one thing
I'll tell you ‐‐
it takes a long time
to go through
the process of approval
with your platform.
I'll make you an offer,
but it's gonna be aggressive,
because I actually
know what the work's like,
and I can bring
a lot of value by just
putting my name on it,
frankly.
I'll give you the 200 grand.
I want 25%.
‐Ruh‐roh.
‐Ooh.
Narrator: Four Sharks are out.
Kevin is Tanya's
last chance for a deal
for her savings account
for kids, Goalsetter.
I'll give you the 200 grand.
I want 25%.
‐Ruh‐roh.
‐Ooh.
I only give the offer
'cause I believe in the mission,
but you don't know yet
what you don't know.
I'm way past
where you are right now.
You've got
a lot of enthusiasm,
but when you get into
the nitty‐gritty
of those banks
that you want to work with,
there's a whole
compliance department
the size of an army.
Kevin, we are in the top two
fintech accelerator programs
in the country.
‐No, no.
There's a thousand
fintech deals.
I get called
by them every day.
We have the vice chairman of
Morgan Stanley who's an advisor.
Come on, Kevin.
It's a reset.
You got to go back
to your investor and say,
"I got Kevin O'Leary.
He's gonna drive this thing."
I know the value
I bring to this.
It just takes you
to a new level.
I'm in this space
every day.
♪♪
I'll double that, Kevin ‐‐
double. 8%.
♪♪
Not doing that.
It's just ‐‐
I'll spend two years
working on it.
Kevin, this ‐‐
I'll end up with zero.
9%, $200,000?
No, no.
No, no, no. No.
I‐I really appreciate
what you're doing,
but I just ‐‐ I've already
seen this movie, Tanya.
You know, I'm talking
myself out of it,
the more I think
about the work.
No, don't!
We're three months away
from interfacing compliance
with a large platform.
No, you're not.
We're gonna do a deal,
Kevin.
We just got to find
the right deal.
And, Tanya, remember,
he's never been wrong...before.
Yeah, that's true.
O'Leary: I‐I'm just
too valuable for this.
Let's ‐‐ I have
to work on it.
Tanya,
you can take my seat
when you make it.
Just show him.
All right, Kevin.
♪♪
I'm sorry,
but you're out.
[ Laughter ]
Well said, Tanya.
Thank you, Tanya.
Thank you.
‐Good luck, Tanya.
‐Thank you.
‐And thank you for that.
‐I appreciate you.
‐Good luck.
‐Thank you very much.
Okay. Bye‐bye.
‐The love affair's over.
‐I love her, though.
‐She's great.
‐I wish I knew the space better.
I just ‐‐ I couldn't
help that space.
[ Groans ]
It is a nightmare.
Hearing Jamie say,
"Hey, prove Kevin wrong,
and you can come up here
and have my seat,"
I'm gonna take Jamie up
on that offer.
I'm gonna be occupying his seat
in four more years.
You just wait.
♪♪
Narrator: In Season 4,
Jim Tselikis and Sabin Lomac
made a deal
with Barbara Corcoran
for their food truck business,
Cousins Maine Lobster.
Barbara,
welcome to the family.
Let's see
how they're doing now.
♪♪
It's amazing what can happen
in six years.
When we started, we had
one food truck in Los Angeles.
Since then, we've grown
into 29 food trucks,
24 different cities,
10 restaurants,
and, guess what,
we're international in Taiwan.
The feedback in Taiwan
is unbelievable.
They're opening
one, two, three.
They're already on their fourth
location in one year.
It's crazy.
And today
is the grand opening
of our 10th restaurant
right here in New York City.
Enjoy. It's hot.
Be careful.
Corcoran: The great thing
about having a restaurant
is you're not chasing
a truck all the time.
You know exactly
where the restaurant is
so you frequent it more.
Any time I get a free lunch
from Barbara, I'm there.
[ Laughter ]
Corcoran: I asked Kevin
and Daymond to stop by today
to show their support to
a great American success story.
How do you feel
now, guys,
that you didn't bid
on this business?
Tselikis: When we pitched on
"Shark Tank" in 2012,
we only had $150,000
in sales.
Lomac:
Now, six years later,
we've done over
$50 million in sales.
Our journey with
"Shark Tank" has been
an absolute
dream come true.
You're creating great jobs
for the people
in the state of Maine,
so keep 'em coming!
Lomac:
The power of this show,
the ability to help
entrepreneurs achieve
their dreams,
to help
their families ‐‐
there's no show
that has ever done
anything of
this magnitude,
and I don't believe
there's ever a show that will.
♪♪
Cramsey:
Time for breakfast.
My name is Lucinda Cramsey.
I was born on a farm
and raised on a farm,
and I'm an eighth‐generation
farmer.
When I was 11, my father died,
and that's when I really
started to understand
how difficult farming
really is.
[ Chickens clucking ]
Family farms are struggling,
and why?
We feed everybody.
Why is it that we put
the food on your table
and we can't put food
on our own tables?
I wanted to give farmers
the opportunity
to be financially independent
outside of big agriculture.
So I created my business,
run by farmers to benefit
small family farms like mine.
I'm very excited for
the amazing things ahead.
Cheers.
To me,
this is my way of life.
This is my culture.
This is my family.
Whoo!
We have fought so hard
to stay on this land,
and we struggled.
♪♪
And, so, yeah,
it's very personal to me.
Farmers don't want a handout.
We want a level playing field,
and with the power
of the Sharks,
we're gonna give 'em one.
♪♪
Hi, there.
I'm Lucinda.
I'm an eighth‐generation farmer
from La Belle, Missouri.
I'm also the founder
and head hen
at a company called Moink ‐‐
moo plus oink.
[ Chuckles ]
I grew up
on a 1,500‐acre farm
where, ironically enough,
it was hard to put food
on the table.
You see, family farms
are struggling,
being snuffed out
by big business.
With 4 companies
controlling over 80%
of the meat industry
here in the United States,
the little guys have been left
fighting for the scraps,
which is why we created Moink,
a meat‐box
subscription company
that connects
tender‐hearted carnivores
with high‐quality,
ethically‐sourced meats.
We offer grass‐fed and
grass‐finished beef and lamb,
pastured pork
and chicken,
wild‐caught
Alaskan salmon.
Our boxes are
fully customizable.
Now, I 'spect we ought to get
to the meat of the matter.
[ Chuckles ]
I am here today
seeking $250,000
in exchange for 10% of Moink
from a Shark who is willing
to double as a pit bull
in our fight
for the family farm.
Oink, oink, who's ready
to get Moink'd?
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐All right, let's get Moink'd.
‐Are there samples?
I'm gonna bring
the bacon to you.
I'm gonna get
some wine there, too?
I 'spect we are.
I couldn't get a job
as a waitress...
Thank you.
...so you're just gonna have
to work with me right here.
Thank you.
And what you're having
on your plate right here
is a rib eye...
‐Thank you.
‐...some bacon...
‐Lucinda, while you're at it,
I want a white
and a red.
Well, that's good 'cause
you're getting both.
'Cause I want to try
the white with the chicken
and the red with the beef.
Well, it's not chicken.
It's pork.
I want the white anyway.
Just give it to me.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Look who wants
the moon over here.
Lord, have mercy.
You're coming in hot, Kevin.
‐Thank you so much.
‐You're welcome.
The pork is excellent.
All right.
Seasoned really nicely.
That is a really fine
piece of bacon.
Mmm.
How'd you come up
with this product?
Cramsey:
So, earlier, you heard me say
that I grew up
on a 1,500‐acre farm.
What I didn't
expand on there
is that when I was 11,
my father took his own life.
‐Oh, no.
‐And so my mother was left
with six mouths to feed and
a farm she couldn't afford.
And so she had to work two jobs
to keep a roof over our head,
and, um, even though
we had all this land,
a lot of times
we were hungry.
It didn't make sense.
And as a result of that,
I really felt like
it was my life mission
to help small family farms
be independent
outside of big ag.
So, the first thing
I start doing, actually,
is doing
fruits and vegetables.
And I've got, like,
a little stand in this building.
And when my lease came up,
I told my customers,
"Look, I'm going
to deliver to you."
Well, that went over
really well,
and, um, a larger company
had said
that they were interested
in coming in and "helping" me.
So, I'm young, dumb, naive,
think the world is
full of wonderful people.
So I made a deal,
gave up 51% of my company,
and zero dollars
changed hands.
So, I learned
a very valuable lesson,
and three weeks later,
I decide I'm gonna sell to them
the rest of my 49%.
I go to my attorney's office,
and I've got, like,
manure on my boots,
my baby's got a dirty face,
like, all those things
you think about
in the sad stories, right?
And so I walk in,
and I said to him,
"You think I can get
$5,000 in cash?"
"Sure, Lucinda, why?"
I said, "Because...
for one day,
I want to feel like
I am not poor, white trash."
And so he said,
"Lucinda, don't let this
be the end of you.
Let it be the beginning."
My husband is a lot better
at raising pigs
than he is potatoes.
[ Chuckles ]
And so we realized
when we started
raising these hogs
that there was a demand.
And so we're talking to some
of our farmer friends
having the same situation,
and finally I went,
"Hey, let's do it
just like we did produce.
Set it up on a subscription box
and ship it to them."
And so that's how
we get Moink.
Tell us about the business,
and what are your sales?
In 2017, we did $85,000
worth of sales.
For 2018, year‐to‐date,
we did $730,000 in sales.
‐Whoa.
‐Big jump.
‐We're cooking with gas.
‐[ Chuckles ]
We have
a 71% retention rate.
Greiner: Wow.
And, Kevin, you're in
the subscription business.
I think you can, uh,
vouch for the fact
that's really good.
That is really good,
but how are you acquiring
the customer in the first place?
So, we do a lot of
inbound marketing right now.
Google people are looking
for this kind of meat,
pasture‐raised pork.
That's getting your SEO search
and all the Internet stuff.
Yes, yes, right.
So, tell us more about
the numbers and the business.
Yeah, let's start with
customer‐acquisition cost,
'cause I'm sure
y'all want to know that.
$97 for a holistic view.
And what I mean by that
is I put everything in there,
including what it costs
for me to pay
a marketing consultant.
What's their
average order?
So, all of
our boxes are $159.
What's the quantity
and the size?
Sure.
So, each box comes with
13 to 16 pounds.
The price per serving
is $4.50.
O'Leary:
I'm trying to figure out
how much you make
on the $730,000.
Yes.
Can you write it down?
'Cause I'm gonna
give the numbers,
and I know you like numbers.
‐I'm ready.
Lucinda, I'm ready.
‐$159,
and our cost is $127.
Greiner: Wait.
That's with
credit card charges ‐‐
‐Wait a minute.
‐That's our box.
‐$127?
‐Yep, that's a 20% ‐‐
‐And you sell it for $159.
‐Let's not get all ‐‐
Is shipping
and handling free?
‐Yes, it is.
‐Ooh, that's bad for margins.
Everybody calm down. Calm down.
We're gonna get there.
So $127 includes
my credit card cost,
my shipping cost,
my box cost, everything.
That's still expensive.
Some of my bacon just
came back up. [ Laughs ]
‐That is a very small margin.
‐There's margin there, Lucinda.
There's no margin.
I understand what
you're saying to me.
Are you basically saying
you're netting 20%?
No, I net about 10%.
Oh, Lucinda!
Lucinda, you want me to give you
$250,000 for 10% ‐‐
imputes a value
of $2.5 million.
Your business isn't worth
$2.5 million.
It's just not.
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in,
but they're concerned
about the small margins
of Lucinda's ethical meat
subscription‐box company, Moink.
O'Leary: Lucinda, I have no
problem with what you're doing,
and it's actually a great story
about perseverance.
I get it.
But your margins are
much less than the other players
in the direct‐protein
marketing business.
Sure.
Omaha Steaks and all
the people underneath them
are making
twice what you make.
If you look at
what's in the box,
they put in other stuff
that's much lower cost.
Sure.
And so their margins
are much higher.
I understand that our margins
are not a lot,
but next year,
if we do $2.5 million ‐‐
You're gonna make
500 grand.
Yeah.
About $380,000 after tax.
That would ‐‐
I didn't come here today
to fight you about my valuation.
‐No, I ‐‐
‐Look, let me tell you.
Do I think
it's worth more? Sure.
You're a force of nature,
Lucinda.
But I'm an investor.
But I also think
my husband's
the most handsome man
in the world.
Doesn't mean I'm willing
to go to war to prove it.
[ Laughs ]
So how about you
give me a number,
and we'll start there.
Lucinda, you know ‐‐
I didn't come to fight you
about this.
Daymond, would you like
to have the floor?
So, I know you got screwed
the first time.
You're very sensitive
to partnerships.
Yeah.
However,
this is our first date...
Yeah.
...and you're
very defensive.
I don't want to get in your way.
I'm out.
You are really
a firecracker,
and I mean that
in a good way.
My issue is that I eat probably
60% to 70% vegetables.
Sure.
And the rest is
a lot of seafood.
Sure.
When I invest in something,
I feel like it has
to fit with me.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Okay.
Look, I have a deal
with Echo Valley Meats.
They've got subscriptions,
and they've got deliveries,
you know?
Congratulations on
what you've accomplished.
But it's just
not a fit for me...
Okay.
...with what I have,
so for those reasons,
I'm out.
‐Okay.
‐Product's incredible.
Best bacon I've ever had,
but I'll tell you something.
Your margins
don't work.
I love the story,
but I'm an investor.
I got to make money.
‐But the thing is ‐‐
So, let's do
the numbers ‐‐
Lucinda, you're talking
to a bunch of Sharks
that don't remember what
it's like to be little.
They want to invest
in big companies.
That's not true.
I remember
what it's like to be little.
Oh, you're so full of...
Are you kidding me?
Siminoff:
The margins you're talking about
are with big companies.
When I was up there,
my margins were terrible.
And as we grew...
The problem was not
your margins.
Your problem was what
you spent on advertising.
No, but as you grow,
you figure it out.
We can get to scale.
‐Uh‐huh.
You know, I invested in
a food company like this.
It's called Kite Hill,
and it's a specialized
cheese company,
and I did it 'cause
I could see the passion
behind the founders
of the company.
I see
the same thing here.
So here's my offer.
I'll give you $400,000
for 20% of the company.
He's giving you
more than you asked for.
Because I think you're actually
asking for too little.
I think we need to get this
to scale faster
to get those margins there.
‐That's a heck of an offer.
But can we talk about ‐‐
Listen, I wouldn't think about
that too long, Lucinda.
Kevin, I'm talking here.
Greiner: Let her think
for a minute, Kevin.
Can you just give me
a minute? Lord.
Okay, so, everything
in my business
has been based on
controlled growth.
I hit numbers
that I say I'm gonna hit.
If I need to put more gas
on something, I do.
If I need to whoa up
on something, I do,
because it's controlled
and calculated.
But now all of a sudden,
you're looking at
uncontrolled growth, right?
You want to be conservative.
We don't want ‐‐
you grow too fast, you're
gonna blow up for sure.
Yeah.
The other side,
though, is
you're growing actually
pretty fast.
Yeah.
And you're gonna need some
infrastructure in place
to lower those margins
to make this a real business
for all of us,
which is why
I'm putting in
more money
than you're asking for,
because I think it's gonna take
some more money to get there.
I have just
one other question.
Are you gonna blow up
my phone a lot?
Is that, like ‐‐
[ Laughter ]
I'm just ‐‐
I am loving you more
and more by the minute.
Okay.
But we got to ‐‐
All right,
let's get 'er done.
$400,000 for ‐‐
Get 'er done.
[ Laughter ]
Deal.
‐Oh, my God.
‐Thank you.
‐Congratulations, Lucinda.
‐Thanks, Jamie.
Love it.
‐Congratulations.
‐We're gonna gonna rock it.
‐Get Moink'd!
[ Humming ]
♪♪
One small step for me,
one large step
for family farms.
How do you like me now?
From a town of 600
to standing here today, wow.
That is gonna be
one interesting relationship.
[ Laughter ]
I love her.
She's great.
I can't wait to see
the follow‐up.
♪♪